you have to train you have to keep your
reflexes so that when you want it it's
there what happens in life we get so
attached to this then we're like always
fighting over this like I want to fight
for this this obstacle we always focus
on the process but we no longer focus on
the outcome the body's like I don't have
it in me to do this and I don't believe
that want to be happy build a life not
just a business hey seven Carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back it lack a belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you to you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something so today let's live
your best belief life and learn the five
lessons that everyone can learn from
martial arts
okay let's kick it off with lesson
number one get humility and discipline
with jaakko willing I remember you one
of the things that stuck with me is I
had a guy that was a traditional martial
artist very very great guy you know and
actually was a seal and he was a
traditional martial artists and you know
I was like a basic jujitsu guy at the
time and you know we decided to figure
out which one worked better right
and you know so it was me as a year long
Jiu Jitsu guy against a guy that had
been crying into his martial art for 20
years this is you know older than me
bigger than me and of course jujitsu one
because jujitsu is better and so then of
course you get the well let's go again
and that's what happens with jujitsu you
know when you get somebody once they
think oh that was you got lucky or
whatever so then you go again and it
usually takes usually takes three to
five times before people recognize that
okay there's something here that I don't
understand and this is a superior this
person will beat me
and so we got through the three to five
repetitions of me submitting him and
he's so now he's kind of a little bit
frustrated and flustered and bummed out
because in his reality is hitting him
that he's he's wasted twenty years of
his life training in the stuff that
doesn't work and so and as he was
scratching to kind of find what he could
hold on to he said to me well the thing
about you know what I do is it's not
just about fighting it teaches you
discipline and humility and at the time
you know I was a stupid kid and almost
like whatever you know I'll still beat
you up so it doesn't matter
and but I took I can't held onto that
and I thought about it and as I continue
to train jiu-jitsu more and more and
especially when I started working with
kids I realized that what the other
older traditional martial arts did to
train you in humility and discipline and
things of that nature
jiu-jitsu absolutely teaches you
humility because you will get submitted
by people on a regular basis people that
are smaller than you people that are
weaker than you and that is a very
humbling experience so you will
absolutely learn humility through
jiu-jitsu and the discipline piece it it
absolutely takes discipline to go and
get on that mat on a daily basis and
prove yourself and if you know there's
some saying about getting your black
belt and it's a very very tiny
percentage of people that start
jiu-jitsu that get their black belt and
that's because it takes discipline and
if you don't have discipline and you
don't learn discipline you'll never get
there so those kind of conceptual things
that they had in traditional martial
arts I think there and and as the
traditional martial arts lost their
realism they held on to these conceptual
ideas
are found in jiu-jitsu in muy Thai in
wrestling they're found there because
they're real and they're a real element
of them and that's a another reason
beyond self-defense to to trained
martial arts lesson number two focused
on the outcome and structure with Dan
lock now mentioned we have a lot of
traffic techniques right trapping tag
the meaning they say I throw a punch to
Peter so here I have an obstacle so from
here I see the strict line and say okay
I'm gonna hit I'm gonna hit Peter in the
chin here but boom I have an obstacle
but what happens in life we get so
attached to this then we're like always
fighting over this like I want to fight
for this this obstacle we always focus
on the process but we no longer focus on
the outcome the outcome is not the hand
the foe the focus is here these are the
branches
we won't guys want to focus on the trees
right so in Wing Chun in Chinese we talk
about Cho Yong bok choy south means we
chase the main the figure not the hands
we only do trapping when there's an
obstacle so when there's an obstacle we
can trap and we can hit
right so we are not thinking about the
hand it's just I try to hit I try to hit
this an obstacle then I can trap and I
can punch right so I'll focus on outcome
we don't lose sight of the outcome
sometimes you're competing with a
company that is much bigger there's got
more resources that's got more capital
there are more people right they have a
better brand
well as a smaller company how do you
beat a bigger guy right
you can doubt which dude i was strength
okay let me look at those guns I mean
they look pretty big right so you're
facing a guy with like a hundred and
fifty pounds 100 200 pounds and 50
pounds that depends on your size if
you've strength vs. strength you're
gonna lose so a Wing Chun is designed to
what they love to for the little guys to
beat the bigger guys and you do don't do
that with strength to do that with
structure so let me give you a prayer
example if I was to like push with Peter
right I'm like using my muscle and like
pushing me it's pushing me like right
but right you can see that again right
guess I have no structure my structure
is off right however if I have the
proper si-wing chin structure right and
then instead of fighting force with
force my structure my shoulders relaxed
right and then I as he's slowly giving
me pressure right now this will act more
a bit more that continue continue see
now the because my structure gives me
strength all his force is now
transferred to the graph like this
rightly bit more lean I live in there
right so it's not straight right it's
not straight right it's just this you
see this is relaxed this I'm not
oblivious see I'm not doing this right
see that you know so structure but if my
structure is walnut semi structure push
you know my structures for all so
structure over strength also if you want
to have more confidence in self-love
checking my 254 series it's free the
Lisa Joyner in the description below
people want to know how to stop the
laziness and they want to know how to
stop the procrastination that's a
problem with young people you're not
good at anything
oh I'm so good no tell me the truth
you're not good at anything it's good to
treat other people the way you would
like to be treated yourself it's like a
golden rule and there's a reason for and
that reason is that working
lesson number three get disciplined and
destroy stress with Joe Rogan most of
what people do is what we're doing right
now most of what people do is sit down
but is that because they don't feel like
running around because some people like
people who exercise generally you have
to put in a little bit of effort to make
yourself go exercise but a lot of people
who are overweight and sick don't have
enough energy to do that I don't know
about that some of them maybe but I
think some of them just don't have
discipline there's an issue with that as
well there's also an issue with momentum
you're not used to doing it it's not a
part of your life it's not something
you're accustomed to pushing yourself
there's been many many many many many
many many days where I didn't want to
work out I just didn't feel like I had
the energy and I just forced myself and
I think there's very few people out
there that know how to force themselves
that's alert yeah it's a learned skill
yeah that that kind of discipline and
focus you have to have like real rigid
requirements of yourself where you don't
allow yourself to back out of things and
you don't allow yourself to slack off
and I don't think people put those kind
of requirements on themselves as if it's
it is a daily principle of life like
what you must get done you know you must
brush your teeth and exercise for 45
minutes and if you did that I think
you'd be healthier and happier and your
body would perform more smoothly and you
if you require your body to do things
like that I think it rises to the
occasion there are very few people that
have that kind of discipline so because
of that they come up with excuses and
excuses are a giant part of the problem
it's not simply a physical health issue
there's also mental aspects of it and
disciplines a big one I just know way
too many people who are weak mentally
and I can't I can't just chalk it off to
only you know their physical though the
way they physically feel because I felt
like a hundred times and then I worked
out and then I felt way better yeah it's
just it's just a fact of life that's
real you know you just can't and I
people don't know how to do that it's
all and if you're used to doing this
getting your car sit down drive to the
office sit down go to
lunch sit down you know go to the board
meeting sit down get in your car on the
way home sit down get home in front of
the TV sit down then go to the gym off
they don't have any energy you know that
their body's not the body's like I don't
know if it in me to do this and I don't
believe that I don't believe that I
think it's it's a lot of it it's the the
mindset one of the things you said is
that it's good to kind of explore your
boundaries when it comes to fear this is
something actually that my meditation
teacher has said to me before and it
made me realize I think I need to get in
there and start pushing it a little bit
in this in the tank because it will help
me in lots of areas of my life because
when you don't test those boundaries
your life becomes smaller and smaller
yeah that happens to people with panic
it I think it well it happens just
people in general and I think it's one
of the reasons why people fall into
panic is because they don't have enough
experience with stressful situations to
the point where they could just relax
and just let it happen and that that's
one of the things that I one of the
reasons why I think martial arts
training is very good for people not
just for the self-defense aspect of it
but for the aspect of just dealing with
stressful situations on a regular basis
to the point where you're very
comfortable with them and then you
realize that the consequences of this is
it's not really as bad as you think it
is like most people are terrified of
physical confrontation but when you have
physical confrontation on a regular
basis especially through my favorite
which is jujitsu training because
there's no striking so you don't get hit
in the head you're not worried about
brain damage or any of that stuff it's
just basically grappling but that
through the continual process of testing
yourself and stress and regular life
stresses sort of become diminished
lesson number four
honestly express yourself with Bruce Lee
ultimately martial art means honestly
expressing yourself now it is very
difficult to do I mean it is easy for me
to put on a show and be cocky and be
flooded with a cocky feeling and then
feel like pretty cool oh and all that oh
I can make all kinds of funny thing you
see what I mean blinded by it or I can
show you some really fancy movement but
to express oneself honestly not lying to
oneself and to express myself honestly
you know that my friend is very hard to
do and you have to Train you have to
keep your reflexes so that when you want
it it's there when you want to move
you're moving and when you move you're
determined to move not taking one inch
not anything less than that if I want to
punch isn't gonna do it man and I'm
gonna do what you see so I mean so that
is the type of thing you have to train
yourself into it to become one with the
you think and listen number five the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is learned to focus with Chuck
Liddell a lot of people when we were - I
started learning karate my I was an old
school style or they trained almost
always which is actually really good for
my my ami was was perfect because it
actually trained me to control myself
and be able to do this is trying to you
know did he sit there with one place and
do this 500 times in a row doesn't fit
your personality what was was tough but
I wanted it so bad got it
that I did it and it trained me to be
able to do that with other things like
be able to concentrate on our test or
and be able to focus what I need to so
I'm got very good at focusing what I
need to do tonight from and I think a
lot of its from that style of teaching
now I have a special bonus tip from Joe
Rogan on how martial arts can eliminate
anxiety though I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that question today I
want to know have you tried martial arts
have you found these benefits or do you
want to try martial arts let me know
down in the comments below and if you
made it this far in a video I want to
celebrate you give me a hash tag believe
in the comments as well and any
long-term cardiovascular exercise you
get this it's like we did you know last
last October we did the sober October
thing we had this crazy fitness
challenge so all of us were doing cardio
like five hours a day really crazy
amounts of cardio and one of things that
Tom Segura and I both agreed on is like
the the amount of
internal chatter dissipates to zero no
give no anxiety it goes on I didn't
realize I had any anxiety until that
happened and then I was like God it goes
to zero it goes to nothing like when you
do like five hours on a treadmill or
just running just run when you when it's
done man there's this like peace of mind
that comes with that this release of
endorphins that's incredibly addictive
because that feeling is so pleasing so
it's not that it doesn't it doesn't feel
good to get out of bed and to just push
when you don't want to but the end
result feels amazing
if you want to know how to start your
day properly with Eric Thomas check out
the video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there I must break all barriers on my
way on my journey to wealth and success
I must break all barriers